il ya de plus en plus d'employeurs qui
réclament le retour des employés au
bureau on se pose la question ce soir où
en sommes-nous avec le télétravail deux
ans et demi plus tard avec nous tania
saba qui professeur en relations
industrielles à l'université de montréal
bonsoir
les patrons de la rbc de scotia
notamment demandé à leurs cadres et à
leurs employés de revenir au bureau en
disant il rien qui peut battre l'énergie
du bureau le plaisir d'être au bureau
les échanges la spontanéité ce que ce
sont des motifs légitimes pour ramener
les travailleurs au bureau absolument ce
sont des motifs légitimes ce qu'il faut
dire d'abord c'est que à travers un peu
les études que nous avons faites des
employés sur des personnes qui ont
télétravailler sont quand même assez peu
nombreux à dire qu'ils voudraient
travailler à distance à temps plein
c'est même moins de 20 % de ces
personnes qu'ils disent par contre il
aimerait garder des activités à distance
en faire d'autres bureaux mais plus en
faveur de la distance donc pourquoi les
motifs sont légitimes parce qu en fait
je peux vous dire que employeurs et
employés voient peut-être le travail à
distance ou d une perspective différente
l'employé s'est dit se dit bah écoutez
ça fait deux ans que j'ai travaillé à
distance j'ai été productif j'ai été bon
et soudainement on veut que je rentre
mais sauf que les dirigeants voient tout
le tissu social tout l'engagement de
l'organisation
la capacité de compétitionner la
capacité de concurrence l'innovation qui
prend quand même un échange qui prend
beaucoup plus une stimulation qui puisse
se faire sur les lieux de travail en
même temps les travailleurs qui sont en
télétravail
aujourd'hui c'est rendu un argument de
taille pour attirer retenir une employée
est ce qu'il ya des employeurs que vous
diriez un peu déconnecté de l'intérêt
réel ou de la volonté réelle des
travailleurs là où les employeurs
deviennent des connectés c'est quand ils
me voient que les risques autour du du
travail à distance et ou bien qu'ils y
pensent que finalement la période
d'avant pandémie a été comme la période
était une panacée or on sait très bien
qu'il y avait des problèmes au travail
qu'on avait des problèmes de
présentéisme qu'on avait des problèmes
de santé mentale que les gens étaient en
burn-out que et là on a quand même d une
méthode
dans une organisation du travail qui
peut permettre une réappropriation du
temps donc la déconnexion c'est de voir
juste le risque est de voir de pas
vouloir encore une fois d'ailleurs ses
dirigeants se sont faits un peu accusé
dans les journaux dans les revues de
gérer un peu par le passé et de ne pas
vouloir prendre un peu 7,7 cette
nouvelle tendance il faut dire que le
télétravail existe encore mais beaucoup
moins de cours de la pandémie en mai
2020 80% des enseignants et travailler à
distance aujourd'hui ses dix sept en
fait décembre 2021 ses 17% et dans les
services publics on est passé de 53 27 %
et encore beaucoup de télétravail mais
beaucoup moins qu'avant c'est quoi des
sources de tensions principale entre les
employeurs et les travailleurs oui les
exemples que vous prenez sont vraiment
de bons exemples sont des exemples où la
présence est importante
l'éducation les services publics et donc
comme vous voyez les personnes sont
retournées dans des grandes proportions
mais il ya quand même des pourcentages
qui reste encore un travail à distance
les secteurs comme la finance les
secteurs de l'administration publique
reste aujourd'hui dans les statistiques
à 60% encore en travail à distance donc
les tensions c'est ce qu'on a vu un peu
c'est des employeurs qui ont obligé des
retours selon certains jours de dire
vous revenez trois jours ça prend trois
jours de présence au bureau alors que
les activités n'ont pas été bien
présentait donc les télétravailleurs au
bureau se disent mais je fais exactement
la même chose que ce que je vais chez
moi à quoi sert ma présence les sources
de tension aussi c'est une culture qui
s'établit où on pense que le télétravail
ou le travail à distance est un
privilège et donc on envoie un message
d'accord on va vous l'accordé cependant
vous savez les bons c'est ceux qui
viennent au bureau les moins bons c'est
ce qu'ils veulent rester chez eux or ça
c'est une grande source de tension
pourquoi parce que ça atteint les femmes
ça atteint aussi les groupes qui sont
sur présentation ou pain qui sont moins
bien intégrés dans les milieux de
travail qui préfèrent rester chez eux on
est presque en train de reproduire les
années 60 au bureau donc ça c'est aussi
à une autre source de tension est ce que
c'est ce que les grands employeurs
comprennent la productivité des
télétravailleurs je vous dirais qu'en ce
moment la productivité d'un travail à
distance prix par personne a été établi
comme tel d'ailleurs on a vu même des
gestionnaires changer d'attitude entre
le début de la pandémie et plus
plusieurs mois plus tard de dire que non
c'est efficace on peut quand même faire
quelque chose ce qui est encore moins
bien étudié puis qui a besoin d'être
expérimenté c'est la modalité hybride ce
n'est pas la même chose la modalité
hybride fait référence à deux formes
d'organisation du travail une en
présence une distance donc il faut aller
chercher un équilibre il faut travailler
en termes d'efficacité qui rallie
performance mieux-être alors que en ce
moment où on prend un contenant qui est
deux jours ou trois jours semaine car on
essaye de le remplir avec des activités
je voyais un journal de montréal ce
matin snc-lavalin va libérer huit étages
de son siège social le canadien national
c'est cet âge-là laurentienne cinq
étages et investissement québec hydro
québec le télétravail s'installe ma foi
oui le télétravail s'installe écoutez
c'est une bonne nouvelle si la façon
comment montréal où les locaux se fait
d'une manière compatible avec les
activités qu'on voudrait garder au
bureau c'est à dire que une majorité
d'activité peut se faire par exemple la
distance on garde aux bureaux des
activités de mise en commun de prise de
décision et dont on a besoin donc
beaucoup plus de salles
multifonctionnelles multimédia etc puis
quelques bureaux partagés si c'est
seulement faire d'économies pour faire
de l'économie demain je vous dirais que
on a des petits problèmes ça veut dire
juste avoir des bureaux partagés ce
n'est pas une panacée c'est vraiment
intéressant en tout cas c'est un gros
changement fort et l essence tania saba
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]